are the rumors true and would you buy a
4k nintendo switch
while 2020 is set to be the year for the
xbox series x and the playstation 5
if the rumors are true then we can
expect an upgraded nintendo switch
right around the corner now most seem to
believe this is just a
4k enabled version of the nintendo
switch but if a recent
patent is any indication it might cause
you to rethink that
and do we really even need a 4k switch
that's our topic
in today's video people of the internet
retrorecontour here i'm just a dad who
loves games and the stories
they tell we post videos twice a week
here on youtube and in today's video
we're talking all about those 4k switch
rumors
so first we'll get you caught up on all
those rumors and what they actually
are then i'll give you my speculation
and finally we'll talk about what
updates you'd actually like to see to
consider buying one of these things
now i'll also include chapter markers
down below so if there's any point in
the video you want to jump to
feel free to use that the latest 4k
switch rumors come to us from bloomberg
normally a trusted and reliable source
when it comes to news sources like this
here's the important bit though quote
nintendo plans to debut an upgraded
model of its switch console next year
along with a lineup of new games people
familiar with the matter said seating
2020's holiday spotlight to rival
devices from sony and microsoft the
specifications of the machine have yet
to be finalized though the kyoto-based
company has looked into including more
computing power and 4k high definition
graphics
close quote now at this point we have
seen this rumor
from multiple sources so even if this
one is the most reliable
they're certainly not the only ones
reporting it now to me the most
interesting part of this is all these
rumors seem to surround the idea
of a 4k enabled switch that's what they
keep focusing on the 4k
capabilities now we've seen these rumors
so many times at this point that i
actually do believe it i think this is
going to happen we will see an
updated version of the nintendo switch
in the first half of 2021. now to be
honest here though i'm a little
skeptical on what the update will
actually include that 4k bit
in particular is really surprising just
when you consider nintendo's history
with hardware for several console
generations now they just haven't cared
about chasing power and updated
resolution
now again going back to that bloomberg
report they said that there's a couple
of different ideas that nintendo has
thought about and they have not yet
finalized those decisions at least we
don't know if they finalized them yet i
would say if this thing is launching in
the first half of 2021
they're at least getting close to the
point of finalizing these details
but is 4k alone really enough for an
update especially when you consider it's
coming from nintendo
yes we've seen their rival competitors
microsoft and sony do this with the last
generation we had the xbox one x and the
playstation 4 pro
of course both of these were more half
steps and none of them had exclusive
games
both of them also focused on updating
the gpu for prettier graphics higher
resolution
even though most games ended up deciding
to give you an option of better
resolution or better frame rates
i do think anyone who owned these
consoles would certainly agree though
that it was far more of an emphasis on
the resolution
than opposed to frame rate i mean to be
honest guys at least for me i don't
think 4k
alone is enough for nintendo to release
an
updated console i already said i think
it's happening but i think there's going
to be another twist to it it's not just
going to be 4k now for me i think there
are three distinct possibilities for
what we could see
number one a standalone pro home
console we already have the switch light
we already have the hybrid switch that
can be docked or taken around anywhere
you want to go
so now what if nintendo goes the other
direction and releases the console for
the tv
only not a hybrid that you can take and
go anywhere with you
this switch pro would fit into the
lineup as the highest priced of all
three models you'd have the switch pro
at the top
the standard switch right there in the
middle and then the switch light as the
handheld only one that's going to be the
cheapest model available there's
actually a little more evidence that
this one could be the case in fact it
comes in the form of a
patent straight from nintendo this
particular patent appears to be a
joy-con without the ability to slide
onto the standard version of the
nintendo switch
now why would nintendo need to release
something like this unless there was
going to be a version of the switch
without the standard joy-con slots
on the side to be fair there are
numerous patents like this as you guys
know that never see the light of day so
this is absolutely something that
nintendo was working on at some point
but maybe it will never come out at all
now the second possibility is that we
get another hybrid just like the current
switch that is simply
updated to run games at higher 4k
resolution when in docked mode
as for the handheld mode maybe they
focus on just updating the screen and
maybe hitting that 1080p
resolution instead in fact 4k is just
not worth it on a screen
that small especially when you think
about the hit it would do to battery
life remember the current nintendo
switch in handheld mode can only output
at a max of 720p so 1080p would be quite
the bump
and last but not least i think there's a
chance a small chance that nintendo
could actually surprise us all and
release a completely
new home console an updated version of
the switch
to compete with ps5 and xbox series x
this would be a full-blown successor to
the current nintendo switch maybe they
call it switch 2 switch pro i don't know
but it would run completely exclusive
games
and also be backwards compatible this
would be similar to option one but in
reality it would be a much more powerful
system that represents a true
next-gen leap for nintendo now
personally i think this is the least
likely one to happen but i do think
there's a chance if i had to take a
guess and had to put money down on this
i would go with
option one i think that is what nintendo
is going to do released a slightly
bumped up version of the current switch
that is set to be for the home only
better frame rates
4k capability they drop the handheld
mode so they don't have to worry about
things like battery life they don't have
to worry about updating the screen
and maybe just maybe they could even
have it at the price of the current
switch
in fact how about this 2021 rolls around
they drop the price of the switch light
they drop the price of the standard
nintendo switch and then the switch pro
comes in
at that current price of the nintendo
switch at 299.
now we should also mention with
microsoft recently announcing the xbox
series
s at 2.99 this is going to make things
even more interesting for nintendo
if they release a home console only
that's underpowered but also at 299
or even more than 299 that puts them in
a very interesting position
again we've already talked about
nintendo traditionally hasn't really
cared all that much
what their rivals are doing i'm actually
curious if you already own a switch what
sorts of upgrades
would you want to see what would make
you go out and say hey you know what i
want to upgrade my nintendo switch
personally i love the hybrid nature of
the current switch the fact that i can
dock it the fact that i can undock it
take it anywhere with me and then dock
it again and be
exactly where i left off has a huge
appeal to me then again there's also the
possibility of the legend of zelda
breath of the wild 2
at 4k glorious 60 fps resolution
yeah that gets me pretty pumped up too
so let me know down in the comments what
you think thank you guys so much for
watching and i'll talk to you again soon